senti ma hai già defollowato tutte le tipe che segui su Instagram?
no perché io te lo dico : non inizio una relazione con un porco!
tu non me la conti giusta!
sei bello sei single hai un bel lavoro
qui gatta ci cova dimmi la veritá
sei uno psicopatico? sei un depravato? sei un sadico?
no guarda scusa cioé quando bevo mi viene sempre da piangere no
perché mi ricordo di quel gattino che è
morto quando avevo quattro anni era
il gatto di mio nonno e io sono
rimasta traumatizzata da questa cosa e
secondo me proprio a livello emozionale
di relazioni questa cosa mi ha veramente
cambiato perché adesso non riesco
più a fidarmi di un uomo
se ti sembro troppo aggressiva sappi che sono leone ascendente capricorno e che questo mese
c'ho pure saturno conto in realtà sono
uscita potessero per fare ingelosire il mio ex
possiamo fare una foto così la
posto e me ne vado
senti ma cambiando argomento
giulia giulia bianchi mi
sembra su instagram perché le metti
sempre like? non mi prendere per una stalker ma vorrei capire chi è la tua ex?
si io sono molto sensibile a questo tema
sono vegetariana da piú o meno 10 anni e lo
faccio per scelta e per principio
proprio perché gli animali non devono
essere toccati
sì per me un doppio cheeseburger con
abbondante bacon non lo sono sempre
vegetariana cioé oggi é come fosse la
domenica per chi sta a dieta ecco
senti non ti fare idee strane peró ho dato
un'occhiata ai tuoi social e ho visto che c'hai una famiglia veramente top!
ma che figa é tua nonna? ah é tua madre?
beh sembra simpatica
ma non ci credo! ti chiami di stefano di cognome?
e hai un fratello che si chiama claudio? no
vabbè
no niente vabe al liceo cose
insomma un pó da liceali non ti sto
adesso a dire senti ma in famiglia avete un fascino irresistibile ma
tuo padre quanti anni ha?
ma sai che ti devo troppo presentare un'amica mia che a lei piacciono i
brutti cioè non i brutti però a me piacciono i belli belli e a lei piacciono i
simpatici simpatici con quelli che
iniziano un pó a perdere i capelli un pó
pelatini ecco e poi soprattutto quelli
con un pó di pancetta lei proprio esce
fuori
senti io sono un pó ipocondriaca quindi
se non mi porti i tuoi esami del sangue entro domani
da me non avrà neanche un bacio
adesso perso la pazienza chi è che ti
sta martellando di chiamate pensi che
sia scema che non lo veda a me non piace uscire con i tipi che sentono altre
ragazze ah é tua madre beh peggio ancora sarai un mammone uno di quelli che non
si schioda da casa fino ai 50 anni
ammazza quanto mangi eh ci credo che c'hai la
pancetta
dopo questa cena devi chiuderti in
palestra ti alleni?almeno quello
ma lo sai che sei spiccicato all'ex mio mo te
faccio vedere la foto bel ragazzo eh
muscoloso possente
io sono single da due anni ormai
il tipo nelle foto?  beh ce ne sono un pó uno é un mio cugino
uno é uno con cui uscivo fino a ieri e ma poi cosa te ne frega
ah non te l'ho detto che sono fidanzata si
si sono fidanzata ma il mio ragazzo non é geloso cioé io non
glielo dico peró se glielo dicessi non sarebbe geloso e quindi facciamo mercoledì e
venerdì sera che lui va a giocare a
calcetto
ci vediamo che dici? avrai capito che sono una molto schietta quindi a casa tua
ci verrei volentieri me farei dare volentieri
una rinfrescatina però ti dico la
verità in mezzo alle gambe c'ho un cespuglio che guarda domani mi sa che devo
chiamare il giardiniere
perché ti sei fatto tatuare chiara sulla spalla
veramente
quanto sei sfigato ti sei tatuato il nome
della tua ex ah é tua mamma? carino
senti ma ho visto una tua foto dell'estate 2016 dove c'eri tu
con questo questo costumino rosso
molto aderente e il cappellino blu ma
insieme a te c'erano altre due ragazze una
tettona bionda e poi c'era una moretta
più bassa con un bel culo
ecco senti ma eri per caso in puglia? no
perché anche io sono stata in puglia
quell'estate magari ci siamo incontrati!
senti tra quattro mesi esatti si sposa
mia sorella no e capisci mi sembra
brutto arrivare da sola quindi vorrei
arrivare accompagnata i miei sarebbero
veramente veramente contenti e tu vuoi
fare la parte del mio fidanzato? e niente
io da piccolina ero un pó cleptomane no andavo nei negozietti rubavo mettevo in
borsa poi mi è passata grazie a dio e
crescendo mi sono ripulita adesso ogni
tanto spaccio ma occasionalmente devo
dire una roba proprio non frequente però
me capita io da sola sto benissimo
però non lo so é un periodo in cui sento
proprio questa esigenza di affetto di
coccole sotto il piumone di massaggini
di un ragazzo che mi va a fare la spesa che mi prepara la cena che mi porta
dall'estetista che mi fa da driver che mi porta a fare shopping senti ma parliamo di cose
serie tu hai dei progetti per il futuro che so matrimonio figli io guarda
entro due anni massimo voglio fare il
matrimonio tre figli cane casa al mare
ma sai che in foto mi sembravi diverso
cioè un pó più aitante un pó più muscoloso
un po più affascinante sei
simpatico bassino ma simpatico almeno
quello dico mamma mia mi sono appena
arrivate guarda cioè non ti dico cosa c'é
qui sotto c'é tipo la terza guerra
mondiale una macelleria sangue che va sangue
che viene senti ma questa
MARYNAOFFICIAL ma chi é cioè perché la
segui ah perché ti piace e guarda se ti
piace lei non ti possa piacere io perché
io sono bionda lei é mora cioé ah é simpatica? perché vuoi dire che io non sono simpatica
guarda io me ne vado veramente continua
a seguire a MARYNAOFFICIAL e magari escici pure
io sono per la parità dei sessi cioè che é sta storia che l'uomo
deve sempre pagare
grazie senti ma ho dimenticato il
portafoglio guarda che testa che c'ho se
per stavolta gentilmente fai te e poi la
prossima faccio io...